Germany's team manager Oliver Bierhoff
became a national hero when he scored
his golden goal against Czech Republic
two decades ago it was the iconic moment
that Clint Germany its most recent
Continental crown I was waiting in the
room today no one came I also had to get
my own coffee every four years I'm
reminded about the goal I will be happy
when we have a different subject to talk
about in four years
like the 2016 title rather than the goal
from 1996 six and nine zero for one
person that could help make that happen
is Toni course he's been superb
distributing the ball in midfield but
the real Madrid player knows that
Saturday's quarter final against Italy
will be a big challenge this will be
special because it will serve as a
measuring stick and Italy will be the
toughest team we've had so far
Italy is Germany's bogie team at least
that's what the media say the Mannschaft
has never won against Italy at a major
tournament explain to me why the word
trauma is nonsense why should I have an
Italian trauma you have to explain that
to me first I can deny it it will likely
be an intense encounter another booking
could see Jerome Boateng miss a possible
semi-final we may even see another
shootout shut down the sunday game I'm
not thinking about yellow cards I will
approach this game the way I always do
we haven't yet practiced penalties today
I don't know if we all will or just a
few players we will try to win in 90
minutes or an extra tile from Joe
because if they don't succeed Oliver
Bierhoff scolding goal will continue to
be a hot topic every four years